hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay I'm got
fisticuffs out let me get out my great
sword okay we got the Horn of jurgen
baller
we killed a dragon we have I finished
downloading counter-strike source
apparently we also got some we learned
fus-ro-dah and so we're good to go and
we need to go infiltrate the Thalmor
something or other I don't know oh yeah
I came to Whiterun because I needed to
sell stuff that's what it was and 5
potions cuz I always need more potions
and then I want a fist fight against
this lady who thought she was all tough
stuff but apparently she was not come on
Lydia sleep with me last night
god what a prude
shut up so I'm not pale ah my volume
wheel on my headset has broken that's
stupid
oh whatever jenos gimme gimme gimme
gimme
you can take all the other crap potions
I have no no no uh nope yeah maybe
probably no screw that
yeah one handed screw that scuba scuba
it restores stamina but it doesn't it
also make you high as a kite something
like that
alright whatever I don't care okay
alright you're useless to me you might
as well be dead for all I care
this is the volume wheel in my thing I
can't hear a bloody thing so if
someone's talk to me then I don't get
the back they call this junk I don't
want to know I call them treasure okay
steel arrows go on take my what no stop
that
Sears like click on no wrong I swear I
swear something ah not again stop it
whatever um I'll keep these
and I got some dragon crap for you but
you don't have any gold what good are
you if you don't have any gold
fine there tick applause Garnett and
that cleans you out shut up
I won't come back not until you have
more gold there are mods that I think
that increase the amount of gold that
the sellers have but I feel like that
would be cheating just a little bit okay
my next stop is you lady I don't claim
to be the boat damn it
grow you anyway I didn't like you to
check inside no matter of our Twitter I
need to go find aa
meeting her back in room ah and I can
stop by the store and sell some more
darkened bones I'll become friends with
someone and they may allow you to take
certain items for your home oh that's
why in this store sometimes I can pick
some stuff up oh that makes more sense
get out my way yeah get out you be
careful Joe I can barely hear anything
you know why this broke
hello baby not you leaving some make
coq10 come on Dorgan bones money fine I
guess that'll do
potions minor whatever here you useless
to me
so are you that light you don't look so
bad wine the right in oh yeah hello baby
are you doing let's go let's go Lydia we
gotta meet this lady warrior priests
person inner secret dungeons basement
totally nothing weird about that
yeah I'm making around hey God we're
just gonna go in here ignore us
completely
you didn't hear thing that is is that
her husband wait what
Roshi use this and make a healing potion
yet nope just still out that blue gone
flower oh wait no I can experiment it I
got more
this that that wrap yes that and that
aha
this that and that well fu - I didn't
care I need it like crunch on these
right fine
get out here what not again
I've been doing this a long time yeah
some sort of party high-risk mission his
name is Mel now born wood elf I'll get
word for him to meet you in solid the
winking while you're doing that I'll
work on
but meet me at the solitude this is
contact you're not dangerous character
luckily he wouldn't be serving I'll just
meet you sounds good
be careful you hear what you're saying
anyway ooh kind a chance some of my
weapons do I have anything to enchant
God just a chance please well I'm gonna
sell them anyway so my eyes look at the
enchant off of them
what can I check you frost damage Oh
insipid in charge what what what do you
mean it's if is in charge I don't have
any soul gems hmm
alright oh uh I never was good at
enchanting anyway you need some sort of
speller
we got rooms and food uh-huh that's nice
guy like organ are I swear these people
have you two rules name talk to Delfy
okay no I need to get to solitude which
means I need to go the stables and once
I've been to solitude I think I have I
think I took at that one time when I
need to get the Horn of Jumanji or
whatever the crap that was called huh
yeah I at least went to that yeah here
we go
boy yeah who's that that's not Lydia
some Imperial lady okay
burials are natives of Cyrodiil the
cosmopolitan it's night chicken lady
yeah you better run I don't even know
where I'm going where where am I going
up here know what there was a path up
here I remember what what I'm this is
wrong this is so wrong no I know we get
up there like the whole path is blocked
off what I'm so confused
I'm so oh oh here okay gravy I said some
nevermind
I panicked for nothing okay alright fine
fine fine fine fine whatever just give
me up this hill i sprint at a 45-degree
angle it don't matter
if you've come to solitude to join them
no I haven't shut up shut up I hope you
guys can hear it okay because I
certainly can't
oh look I've been having audio problems
for a long time for a few days now
straight like just the mic goes crappy
audio cuts out some for some reasons my
my audio didn't record at all for an
entire episode and I had to redo it
position uh-huh this is where this guy
guys
yeah all with it what huh who's a [ __ ]
ah no alright let's just gone away you
betrayed if you want to see that guy die
you're all sick trick the winking Lydia
went and yargh
okay areas Harry is now born really
here's the deal
uh huh I can smuggle some equipment into
the embassy for huh huh
don't plan on bringing anything else in
with you uh-huh the Thalmor take
security very serious Oh give me what
you can't live without and I'll make
sure to get it into the embassy the rest
is up to you okay
you're asking me if you actually want to
get out alive I'd bring whatever you
need to move quietly until I move loudly
and I kill even louder all right
I'm fine you can take my the embassy
Florida gotta go
I'll find you at the park I said don't
worry take my sword
I guess my armor I'll just walk around
naked America me what happens if I have
my long boat with me let's like do
anything
no no no whatever else
maybe they're gonna take everything away
from me probably probably
yeah ah what I wanted to give you
potions whatever whatever I don't need
them I don't need them things why I'm
naked
what ever if I work instead of putting
something on screwing you I'm gorgeous
oh look at my physique you jealous Lydia
you jelly you jelly Lydia you jelly I've
got your back you jealous go and join me
naked party to carry me
yeah I thought so
hey baby that's how you let me go to a
party oh yeah way I still got gauntlets
on what the hell it's completely
nakedness gone let's get out of here
that's right
I got my pickaxe yeah I'm gonna pawn off
some [ __ ] and excessively high bounty
will cause a holes guard a holds guards
to attack oh yeah where am I going
Delphina at the stables all right
whoosh
don't look at all let's go to this party
ever I'm naked what do you think about
that hmm
don't tell me you're not impressed good
but the only one which means you need to
look the part and put what on party
clothes I don't want to put on party
embassy dress
what
I look like a douche are you kidding I
have to do you should pass for a real
guest oh okay fine sure good there goes
all of my things in depth here I go what
I care douche let's go to this party
bashing with a shield we'll stagger an
opponent if time prize there you go I
will thank you madam come on Lydia
let's go Lydia let's go have some fun
this isn't probably a nice party but
nothing like my birthday party which was
awesome by the way
hello we've met I am Lord tickle Wiggly
my name is markiplier ah yes I remember
your name please
Melbourne's
it's wires do I have your permission to
uncork the okay whatever I don't care
they're being unapologetically boring
what are you doing what are you doing I
was going baby I won't boo you
you don't know baby lady how's it going
over there
I'm fun what can I get for you you made
it in good
uh-huh as soon as you distract the
guards I'll open this door let's hope we
both live through this day of course let
me see if we have another bottle of that
uh I'll be waiting by the door for
everyone to be distracted okay
distraction distraction Lydia get naked
Lydia Lydia come on it's for the mission
please just flash people god I'll get
naked oh you're talking to
what do I do to make a distraction you
we're not supposed to talk to yes oh
yeah
how about this for talking what what I
can't yeah the Great War is long past it
you must be I feel that it's time I put
aside peace and prosperity right
unlikely the pots of money what are you
doing what are you doing I hope you
enjoy like a drink sir thank you can we
get up I'm supposed to do fine I'll get
drunk ah quest items alright I ran out
of time for this episode I'll figure out
what to do in the next one the drink
thank you all so much for watching and
as always see you in the next part
bye bye